dreams has been to go back to the Holy Land I had a chance to visit Israel with my
family when I was about 10 years old and I'll never forget being at the Temple Mount
walking through Hezekiah's tunnel and of course having a chance to ride on a camel
but going back recently with a student group that I led was life-changing on the
recent trip I had a chance to take a boat ride in the Sea of Galilee visit Beth She
'an where the Bible describes that the body of King Saul was hung see the remains of
Jericho with my own eyes and I got to go to the pool Bethesda where John 5 describes
that Jesus healed a paralytic seeing many of these places with my own eyes really made
the biblical stories come alive but it got me thinking more than ever how does the
biblical account match up with the archaeological record maybe you've heard people
say that archaeology proves the bible is true well that is certainly an
overstatement after all many fictional stories can be based upon real people events
and places but what archaeology can do is show that the biblical writers were
careful you see the archaeological record can be part of a larger case showing
that the bible is trustworthy before we take a look at two of my favorite examples
of archaeological evidence that support the reliability of the Bible,
Keep a couple things in mind. First off, the archaeological record is incomplete.
There's many things we haven't found.
In fact, there's many things we probably will never find.
There's a lot of things that have just disintegrated and been destroyed.
So if you expect the archaeological record to be complete, you're going to be
disappointed. But second, taken as a whole, the archaeological record supports the
stories as found in the Bible there are many many findings that support that the
biblical writers got it correct let's look at a couple examples
first in John chapter 5 John reports one of the most famous miracles of Jesus where
he heals a paralytic in Bethesda at a pool that's surrounded by five
colonnades now critics almost unanimously dismiss this as being a fabrication
because it's such an unusual description yet when archaeologists dug in
bethesda guess what they found they found exactly what john described a pool
surrounded by five colonnades and i got to visit bethesda and see this
with my own eyes
john describes how people sought out the healing powers of the pool because it was
believed that whoever got there when it was stirred first would be healed yet the
paralytic was stuck and yet Jesus healed him anyways now this finding
doesn't prove that the Gospel of John is entirely true it doesn't necessarily prove
that the story happened but it shows that John got his facts in his description
about the events right long before archaeologists could even excavate the area
it shows that john is a careful writer second critics have often
questioned whether jesus was really nailed to the cross as the gospels describe you
see in the gospel john it says that thomas wants to see the nail marks in his hand
and in his feet which indicates the belief that jesus was nailed to the cross and
yet all the crucified victims that people found had actually been crucified with
ropes does this mean that the author of the gospel of john got it wrong yet in
1968 an ossuary was discovered that contained the bones of a crucified man by the
name of Yehohanan and it dated to the late 20s roughly during the time that jesus
was crucified under the reign of pontius pilate as they opened up the ossuary
they discovered that lodged into the heel bone was an 11.5 centimeter
spike and interestingly enough the shin bones seem to have been
shattered which matches the description of the death of the two criminals who were
crucified alongside jesus as is described in the gospel of john by itself
this doesn't prove that jesus was crucified but it does show that the gospel of
john the writer got his facts right about how people were crucified long
before the archeological record came to light.
The author of John got it right.
Examples like this could be multiplied.
For example, recently a pottery inscription has been found with the name Goliath
that dates to the time of the biblical account.
And in northern Israel another inscription has been found that refers to the house
of David and an ossuary has been discovered that seems to be of the historical
figure Caiaphas who is the high priest when Jesus was condemned to death.
The archaeological record has consistently provided support for the reliability of
the Bible. When you combine the archaeological findings with the willingness of the
Apostles to die for their belief, the manuscript evidence, and fulfilled prophecy we
have a strong case for the trustworthiness of the scriptures on my recent trip to
israel i had a chance to meet with a friend of mine who at the time was a phd
student in archaeology at Hebrew University and he took me and the students up to
see the cave where they first discovered the dead sea scrolls and i asked him i said
in israel as a whole what do people think about the historical jesus what he said
surprised me he said there is general agreement on the basic facts around the
story of Jesus and certainly that He exists.
He said there's general agreement about where Jesus was born, about where He grew
up, where He ministered, and where He died.
And so I asked him, I said, so why do you think more people don't believe?
And I'll never forget what he said.
He said, I really believe it's spiritual blindness.
You see, God is not going to force anybody to believe, but those with eyes to
see and with ears to hear, God has made himself known.
The question is, are you going to believe the gospel, apply it to your life, and
live it out? What could be more important than that?